So, Leute.
Der Zug ist da. Mein ICE-Reisebericht beginnt.
Let's go!
Herzlich willkommen bei der Deutschen Bahn.
Eier, gekochte Eier!
Ein Ei nur 35 Cent.
Ich bitte um Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Bitte begeben Sie sich auf Ihren Platz.
Es muss alles seine Ordnung haben.
What the f ...
Entschuldigung.
Ich suche Sitzplatz zwölf.
Bin ich denn hier richtig?
*Lachen*
Warum muss Bahnfahren so kompliziert sein?
Es hat alles seine Ordnung.
Sie wollen uns verrückt machen,
damit wir uns gegenseitig zerfleischen ...
... und nicht gegen die vorne
in der Bahn rebellieren.
An die kommt keiner ran.
Habe ich selbst probiert,
als ich noch jung und naiv war.
Wie lange sind Sie denn schon hier?
Seit zwei Stunden.
Was ist eigentlich mit Ihrem Bein passiert?
Erfrierung.
Bin direkt neben der Klimaanlage eingeschlafen.
Egal.
Ein Körperteil weniger, das schwitzt, ...
... wenn im Sommer die Klima kaputt ist
und hier 50 Grad herrschen.
So können die uns doch nicht behandeln.
Ich meine, wir sind immer noch Menschen.
Ich bitte um Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Die Nutzung
der Bordtoiletten ist auf eigene Gefahr.
Das bringt doch nichts.
Warum nimmst du denn nicht
einen netten Stehplatz beim Eiermann ...
... und lebst einfach dein Leben?
Weil ich reserviert habe.
Und zwar genau da!
Entschuldigen Sie, ...
... das ist mein Platz.
Unwahrscheinlich,
weil ich habe den reserviert.
Schauen Sie lieber noch mal nach.
Muss ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich Doppelbuchung.
Der Zug ist überfüllt.
Passiert ständig.
Dann zeigen Sie mir doch Ihr Ticket.
Ich sitze schon richtig.
Da war ich wohl schneller.
Dann zeigen Sie mir doch Ihr Ticket.
Zeigen Sie mir Ihr Ticket!
Gute Fahrt.
Dann bleiben uns nur die unbeliebten Plätze.
Ich bitte um Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Momentan haben wir leider
eine Verzögerung von 291 Minuten.
Wir bitten, dies zu entschuldigen.
Oh! Oh! Oh!
Was ist das?
Es ist wunderschön.
Die erste Klasse.
Aber die ist nicht für Menschen wie uns.
Warum?
Der Zug ist komplett überbucht.
Die sollen uns da reinlassen.
Hey! Hey! Hey!
Auch wir haben Recht
auf Komfort und kostenloses WLAN.
Hey! Wenn die Fahrt schon
so langsam und teuer ist.
Hey, lasst mich!
Hey Krückenmann!
Warum arbeitest du für die?
Weil die Ordnung eingehalten werden muss.
Ich will unbegrenztes WLAN!